I am so excited because we are giving
away a Canon M 50 camera a Joby
Gorillapod 3k a rode ntg-2 mic that I
don't have with me right now and so if
you'd like to win the camera smash the
like button wherever you're watching
this and I'll give you all the details
look we've been doing a challenge I
don't know if you've been a part of this
but we've been doing a 7-day YouTube
challenge I'm gonna give you details
about that if for some reason we're just
meeting my name is Sean kennel my
passion is helping people build their
influence with YouTube I wrote a book
with my friend Benji Travis called
YouTube secrets and I'm so fired up
because we've been doing a bunch of
giveaways we have more coming up but
we're doing another one soon and so the
way you enter is you just got to show up
live to the YouTube influencer challenge
now if you sign up for the YouTube
influencer challenge at tube influence
calm if you're watching this over on
YouTube there's a link in the
description if you're on Facebook could
somebody do me a favor and just type
that out in the comments tu be e
influence calm we are doing a session
coming up at 5 p.m. Pacific time so it's
actually very soon so if you're catching
this video on the replay you just want
to get here for the next giveaway of the
YouTube influencer challenge now let me
ask it's good to see you era and
Kourtney and Drew Barry have you guys
already seen the YouTube influencer
challenge over here on YouTube angel
Tati have you guys been a part of the
challenge yet smash like opinion value
smash like if you have no idea what I'm
talking about or press the like button
gently thanks Doug for typing that out
what we've been doing is we've been
breaking down our proprietary process of
growing your influence on YouTube it's a
seven step framework and if you're late
to this training I've seen some people
binging it there is about there's almost
a day's worth of content it's about 14
sessions and it's just been amazing and
so the way you get access to all that
and that's where the giveaway is
happening so if you go to tube influence
comm you can sign up
and that's how you can get access to the
private group it's over on Facebook some
people said I don't have facebook and we
said well I guess you can't see the
content but you know sorry it's so it's
this challenge group here and if you
actually check out the videos there's
always a countdown so they're not super
labeled you know 2 hours 1 hour and 25
minutes two and a half hours because
there's QA on them all of these sessions
have been just amazing where we're
breaking down what we typically teach
inside of some of our paid programs and
courses starting YouTube right making
money on YouTube getting views on
YouTube and so on you can watch these
replays we've had Heather tourists Toni
Arriola Melissa Caputo breaking things
down Tony's doing his tip of the day
Heather's been breaking down massive
fire good to see you John you know Nando
said he's seen everyone that's what I'm
talking about
so Nando let me know bro what do you
think like did you get value out of it
was worth your time you know on think
marketing here did you see it interior
design sub you know maybe one out of ten
what he's been thinking like what's a
big take away I see change in our hearts
obviously all in you've been there and
so all about Annie's been there for all
seven days let me know some of your guys
takeaways and let me know what you've
been learning on the challenge but
number one we're about to give this
camera away we've got about a half hour
until that happens and we've got a
session coming up number two if you
happen to just be seeing this video I
encourage you there's about 36 hours to
catch up on the replays and then there's
also an option to get the recordings but
you can watch this whole challenge for
free and that's what this has been it's
been a seven day youtube challenge
what's that every day there's been
something to learn every day every day
there's been something to do so like
we've been helping you with titles
having you post your thumbnails and you
know we have a course called video
ranking Academy and it's a seven step
framework but we've been going through
the whole thing for free in this live
YouTube influencer challenge jail said
it's so worth it a gangster the feedback
Michael said the videos have been
invaluable I really appreciate that
feedback Sandra said these sessions have
not been only amazing but for business
in general and I love that she mentioned
that Sandra because or Sandra let me
know how to pronounce it um you know
YouTube so much bigger than YouTube like
if you really want to make an impact on
YouTube you do really need skills and a
strategy I believe to think about online
business online marketing self-awareness
knowing yourself and building your
confidence as well as the tactics and
strategies for crushing it on YouTube
and so man it's been so amazing so
here's the final detail smashed like if
you've been enjoying the challenge over
here on think marketing or on Facebook
if you're just hearing about it go to
tube influence comm where you can watch
all the training we also are doing a
super like crazy never before done way
to get into some more coaching and
courses with us bundle called the
YouTube influencer bundle but whether
that's right for you or not this
challenge is there and for a few more
hours
we're giving away tomorrow morning we're
giving away gift cards I think some more
tech we've got okay I do I do know we
have we have a podcast set up like boom
arm USB mic still coming up but in the
next half hour we're giving away the
cannon m50 the rode ntg-2 a lot of cool
stuff and we've been giving away some
other things as well so some amazing
things coming up I'm so proud of the
thick media team as well as you for
taking notes for showing up for leaning
in for being engaged for investing in
yourself for investing in your learning
and for really maximizing this time
right now you know to add a little bit
of why it's so important to go all-in on
YouTube right now I think we've seen it
the world's been so disrupted because of
this pandemic and what's happening
Twitter is never gonna make their
employees come back to work they're
gonna work remote people when it comes
to live streaming webcams USB mics
livestream live
right now when it comes to webs like
live-streaming I'm using extreme yard by
the way and if you ever curious what
tools we use just go to think media
tools calm and we talk about the various
gear
I love streaming Eric's is so easy and
I'm going live on two different
platforms right now I'm over on thick
marketing as well as my Facebook page my
public page live streaming YouTube
digital video is that you need it like
you got you've got to be kidding we're
never going back I'm not trying to say
we're never gonna open up completely and
and and have life go back to normal but
everybody understands now you got to
have an online business you got to have
an online offer even if you also have a
physical business so mastering YouTube
getting online getting confident on
camera learning the strategies plus I
think there's also the side of things
where we've learned that Nielsen saw
that content consumptions going up more
people are learning from home consuming
content from home watching YouTube from
home so that's what this challenge has
been in response to at think media we're
like let's do something for our
community and even if you're just new to
our community to giveaway strategies
tactics momentum and to really get
people going all-in come on to type all
in to to get some serious impact with
their YouTube channel even if you're
just starting or if you ultimately want
to scale the YouTube channel you already
have and so and then not only that
ecommerce what does that mean
online shopping order volumes up by at
least 50% so you got to be leaning into
affiliate marketing right now right
affiliate marketing making money online
and even business owners that have been
that have brick and born or businesses
meta so good to see Russell and
everyone's typing all in Annie angel
good to see ya Matthew get to see over
on Facebook Michael all in it's good
it's so great to see everybody leaning
in and we got to lean into affiliate
marketing or e-commerce affiliate
marketing is simply a way to sell a
product
that you know is you don't have to own
the product or ship the product and we
don't have time to go into that but of
course we talked about that on the think
marketing podcast and everywhere else so
the session we've been doing everything
in Los Angeles time West Coast time let
me know if you have any questions PJ
Sean did affiliate marketing also get
affected with this pandemic since Amazon
is kind of slowing down its influx of
orders a couple things I feel incredibly
blessed because we've sort of been
protected because of our niche and
that's that's because I think everyone
is like I need a camera
I need a tripod I need a microphone you
know if you didn't see what you probably
didn't see I don't know why you would
have but Amazon I was actually on CNBC
in this video about about how Amazon is
slowing down their orders and is
actually they're doing a little mini
documentary on the day in the life of
Amazon proper myself and it's been kind
of fun to work on that project but we
are can't our category cameras did not
get affected so I just we like dodged a
bullet
some a lot of categories got slashed 50%
to 80% meaning you normally made like 8%
on Amazon affiliates now you make 4 or 6
9 make 3 so we've been seeing just
incredible order in a lot of our
affiliate marketing and and so it's been
super powerful and something like over
$30,000 so far this month in profit
that's about eight hundred and forty
eight thousand dollars in for Amazon
sales so I know this is just one side of
the market and obviously we're blessed
with you know the camera photo and video
is our largest category naturally
because of think media but I mean that's
crazy
shipped order revenue I mean that's two
hundred ninety thousand clicks so where
does this money I'll correlate from
because of the volume right we're
playing this at a pretty big level but
here's what I'm trying to say on this
YouTube influencer challenge we've been
talking about like what if you just had
like a couple extra
dollars a month it changed your life
back when I started video or started
doing YouTube in affiliate marketing I
was making 200 extra dollars a month or
350 extra dollars a month around
Christmas time with family or when Sonia
and I were struggling financially that's
serious money that seriously moves the
needle obviously this needs families now
because we've got a bigger team and
think media and all kinds of content
creators and stuff but yeah
affiliate marketing man that's what is
this illustrate ecommerce it's not just
Amazon it is people shopping online
locked-down shopping from home you got
to get in the game you got to lean into
this and so if you haven't registered
then get registered the giveaway
starting soon YouTube influencer
seven-day challenge tube influencer calm
is where you register and smash like if
you've been fired up by this whole thing
and I wanted to show you my little cameo
in this video and I think a deeper dive
is coming out with me soon but yeah they
were talking about how yeah Amazon's
trying to trying to slow down the order
of volume because they can't even keep
up with it
mainly because of you know essential
things too like all the toilet paper and
all of the cleaners and all of that kind
of stuff and I have no idea why this
just loading so slow but I had my mom I
was like look mom I'm on the noose whoa
there he is you know
Amazon affiliate marketer and so a
little thick media so that's kind of
cool you know 1.6 million subscribers
over on CNBC almost 500,000 views on
this little video here so shout out to
the CM VC spot and get into the
challenge it's time the time is now and
thanks so much for being a part of it so
look if you're just joining I'm gonna
get ready jump on with Heather and and
Mel and Tony we're giving this camera
way soon this camera set up and I want
to encourage you of course this is like
the greatest setup in our opinion we
still love the m50 flip screen mic input
you know good for vlogging
for live-streaming we're gonna put some
new videos out you know cannons got
these new updates where you can just
livestream off their cameras with USB
cables it's crazy and so you know this
is a great camera but remember the best
camera to have is the camera you already
do have it's all about the content value
not the production value 50 dollar
webcam although during the pandemic it's
four hundred and fifty dollars I'm sorry
I know like everything's backwards
literally WebKit it's a webcam famine
right now like it's awful it's so hard
if get like everyone's I think it's cuz
a lot of schools a lot of students or
ordering webcams
but the principle is the same you know
webcam or the smartphone you already
have or settin it up you gotta be
creating content and whether you do the
influencer challenge with us or not you
got to press record you got a punch fair
in the face punch perfectionism in the
face and press record Diane's here
come on Las Vegas she's used her phone
for 87 videos what excuse do you have
we've been killing excuses on this
challenge
I've been disrespecting the excuses
Shawn I just still have the energy to go
live look up the Berkshire Hathaway
annual conference that just happened in
the last couple weeks and you can watch
Warren Buffett who's 89 years old go
live for five hours straight and talk
the whole time if you don't got energy
to create content you're making excuses
video do Warren Buffett's going live for
five hours and dropping like knowledge
at 89 years old could it be that it's
our fear or our hesitation or a
procrastination or ourselves out that's
holding us back and not actually what
we're labeling is excuses come on we're
here to smother kill excuses Shawn
you're not being nice to me because I
want you uncomfortable man that's why
you watch think marketing that's why you
watch think media come on we got to get
you creating content come on you're
building a legacy you're fighting for
your fam
you're fighting for your future my life
changed during the hardest season in my
life 2009 recession my wife Sonya almost
dies we're losing two homes my church is
falling apart which I'd been a part-time
staff there and everything around us was
falling apart we lived in Marysville
Washington an hour north of Seattle
Washington
so this gray here is real because I've
actually been through recessions and
I've been through major setbacks and
I've been through short selling homes
and I've been through financial
devastation and I've been through being
terrified because of chronic illness and
health challenges in our home and I've
been through a lot of hard stuff and I'm
not saying cry me a river one way or
another you've either been through
harder stuff or you haven't but we're
all on our own journey I'm here to say
that in the middle of this pandemic in
this hard season you got to lean in and
stop making excuses and start getting
results you can either have excuses or
results but you can't have both
and when we're giving you a free
challenge watch Netflix instead I need
to finish final fantasy seven soon I've
been crushed in Final Fantasy I'm like
twenty two hours into Final Fantasy
seven super fun remake I think it's
gonna probably take me you know 40 hours
to beat it but their spacing out these
get like the whole attitude turns look
punt your leisure your Netflix your ps4
put it to the side and work on yourself
and work on your future that's what I'm
saying this challenge is all about you
can do it first season not much longer
to get into the replays and so um tube
influence calm appreciate you just press
record we're giving away a cannon m50 in
just a few minutes I gotta jump off hit
the like button thanks for being here
coffee with Cannell is coming up Lila
and Johnson go to tube influence calm
and then we email you all your
enrollment instructions where you can
get in so if you go to Johan son
tube influence calm and Don's been in
there it's been amazing seven days jlc
over there in just a second
appreciate you I love recovering addict
it's been our 65th live stream in a row
helping those affected by drugs and
alcohol that's what I'm talking about
going live sharing a message that
matters sharing out of your life so
powerful and yeah yeah yeah so if you
want to still get in the challenge I
pull an all-nighter man this is free
I've I've got cuts and blood on my face
and fatigue and back pain from crushing
it for the last decade to pioneer and
learn this stuff I have failed YouTube
channels I got successful YouTube
channels
I got gold play buttons I got sober play
buttons I've put into work man and I'm
breaking down all that stuff with the
rest that think media team but you gotta
you got to jump in and I'm just saying
on the replays of course we're gonna
keep going on think marketing and new
videos I'm think media but for we've
ever anything like this before so that's
a tube influence calm giveaway coming up
in a few minutes killing the faux paux
you got to be a part of the challenge to
know what that means
fear of other people's opinions the
f-word people got all uncomfortable you
got to leverage the f-word you got to
feed your faith kill your fear and use
your failures as stepping stones to
success jessica is all-in she got the
starter kit thanks so much for being a
part of the challenge and let's talk
soon man we're going live right now so
I'll see you over there
at in the group if you're just joining
hit the link in the YouTube description
or maybe on Facebook and you type in you
know ww tube influencer calm hit that
link get signed up quick and join us in
the group because we're doing this
camera giveaway keep crushing it keep
smashing it subscribe here and hit like
and like page to see future content
that's gonna help you build your
influence make a greater impact we're on
a mission to help 10,000 Purpose Driven
entrepreneurs make a difference in the
world with online video and make a
full-time living
see you soon see in the next video
coffee with Cannell 10 a.m. Pt tomorrow
I'll be streaming here at the same place
taking your questions and bringing you
on no no no no I take that back on
Thursday this week that's fit May 21st
tomorrow we have a bonus session inside
of the challenge group so you got some
time we got giveaways coming up and
whatnot ten o'clock tomorrow next
challenge session I think 10 a.m. Friday
Thursday you know what I gotta go I I
don't even I'm not making sense so this
is the worst ending and just to
crash-lands tries to end with the
mission statement crash and burn I hope
tonight session does it go like this
love ya see you over on the challenge
then and keep crushing it keep smashing
it we will talk soon